he's what we going to do you've all got
different rectangles but I want us all
to be able to compare in some way okay
so let's say that the squeege started
off with let's say that's where I had
side leg one okay let's say for everyone
no matter how big your diagram is let's
call that side leg the square one now
therefore let's just walk through how we
constructed this dear okay what was the
first point last year to put him in it
was this midpoint right so that
immediately tells you this is one and
this little distance down here should be
hello right no problems okay good all
right well now you've got a half there
how can i progress to work out the ratio
between this side from the square to
this do you rectangle that I built can
you see how I'm gonna get there hmm
the people who did it by rule of mine
actually see it a little more clearly
than people we did it by compass even if
it comes be a little how we're gonna get
thinner with this distance right that's
where we're gonna go where do you
suggest a goodness well I'm the length
of the midpoint to the court of good
okay so I'm after all hypotenuse here
right
how am I going to do it okay so this is
one because it's the square okay so you
do your plate there you sit here let's
just quickly do it okay square of oh
good let's just do the numbers on the
square behind one you straight is this
is is not lost is the sum of the squares
of the other two sides like so okay so
on this I'm getting one plus a quarter
that's five quarters okay so there you
go you get your hypotenuse by taking the
positive because what I'm interested in
length so that's why you got to worry
about the negative square roots okay
excellent so now we have this distance
that got measured mentioned before right
the square root of five there it is
right but what do we do in this length
we brought it down over here didn't we
these are radii of this largest circle
with the whole thing I have drawn but
you've got me on right
so therefore this distance let's see
where shall I write it op is half over
here now it's the same this that's the
radius right that's my square root of 5
over 2 okay so what are the ratios of
the sides the ratio this site is just 1
so it's 1 2 whatever this number is well
the whole loop here right because they
both wanted to know then - I just say
well 1 plus odd - okay hey your
calculators Dan right what's that number
1 plus square root of 5
Cassie with your brackets what do you
get
if I am let's do it let's do three
decimal places that's usually how far
they go I think you should get one six
one eight and this number is so
important this ratio here is the golden
ratio this rectangle we've drawn is the
golden rectangle okay this number
because it comes up so many times with
your name we call it five there you go
you know you've made it if you're a
number and you get given the Greek
letter as a name cool unimportant right
so Phi right that's this 1.618 number
then now it comes up all the other bits
in fact it doesn't just come up in
Georgia I'll show you by the way if you
were to draw the ohms the great pyramid
and look at its side on if I went here
and formed a triangle here if this was
one and this would be fine over there
the hypotenuse okay so I know you're
like oh no great date was there I know
but the golden ratio is in there
nonetheless
okay it's quite a slender she actually
it's not just in big things it's not
just gonna be big in fact if you get at
your wallets I can almost certainly
guarantee that you will have a golden
rectangle on you get your wallet up now
let's see which one should I choose
let's get adds up the unit camps I'm
gonna fly by his cocky eyes okay
I could get out of credit capital I'm
mindful about the other side okay now
get out your convict get out Yukon yeah
you should have a car which is the same
dimensions as mine roughly at least if
you go measure it depending on your
accuracy and I know this slight
modification three times what is you
what do you get as the dimensions of
your credit card you've got a long side
and a short side come on give it to me
to the nearest millimeter what are you
getting five point three eight point six
good now yours might be five point four
or eight point five or you get the idea
guess what this is within a millimeter
of the golden ratio
that's really wicked traumatic sound
you're gonna make sure okay well you get
my points right that even in seemingly
innocuous places the places you would
least expect okay you find a golden
ratio and we're not even getting started
yeah before we move on let me give you a
picture this what we're about to do okay
if you had not young how many use a
teacher for very long as you may not
have discovered this but I'm really into
metaphors and analogies okay so remember
I said we're thinking deeply about a
simple thing feel what a best place to
do that is to think about these maps
this is a diamond right again a quick
essentially beautiful object right
everyone recognizes this it's not just
that they're rare people look at them in
they're like wow
now unfortunately and I looked actually
for this and I couldn't find a good
example one of the things that makes
time it's so beautiful is that where
they are really good jewel on its own
right and doesn't just have like what in
the graph actually cuts it and closet
and that kind of thing you get this kind
of geometry
now the geometry is very very
interesting because you look at it right
you can see all the lights and colors
coming out of it right but that
astonishing thing is that you know most
of us probably will not ever get to do
this or maybe when you pull more all
that and you've got enough money to do
this if you can get a hold of the
diamonds and there's many things right
and just move it a little bit in your
hand and look at it from slightly
different angles all these colors here
they all change completely but you see a
whole new Beauty to the figure ok just
by looking at a different angle so what
we gonna do is we investigating this
golden ratio business from one angle
right namely this geometric angle okay
we're gonna see it from a couple of
different ways to try and appreciate
what's beautiful data okay so you're a
rectangle there let's roll this off
and but you can leave a teacher there
actually and I want you to make this
little dull point algebraic definition
now this sounds very pedestrian right
sounds very pedestrian algebraic
definition sounds as formal as it gets
right but we're gonna try and understand
well this find alteration business right
it doesn't just come from rectangles it
comes up all other kinds of places
what's special about it
we'll get how we constructed this thing
you've already worked out that this lake
down here is 1 plus root 5 on to tell me
what's this distance equal to we made a
new rectangle that was bigger but we
also made an erect angle that was
smaller right what is this length yeah
ok good good
you can see that if that this is there I
can take away this distance which we
already said was a half right so you're
getting this ok now part of what makes
beautiful right is that what you divided
this side by this side this is big one
by this one you've got that one Prince
in 2005 right well then have a look at
this rectangle in here and look
carefully at your one the one you've
constructed is there not something
familiar about it let me help you to see
it okay you've got you've got a
calculator right and so what I'm gonna
do is were the same angle in here right
what would happen if I worked out its
ratios long side divided by short side
yeah and I've got now it's this is the
long side this is the long side and this
is the short side so work out the ratios
in this retaining wall I would say one
per bar this one I'm going big divided
by small big divided by small you see
what I'm doing
all right well divided by a fraction
right
two over five minus one
yes now hold on a second you could reach
me a calculator to you and you really
send it but you don't need to you know
what to do with this we can do something
with this right if I said to you
simplify this 2 over 5 minus 1 we don't
you know as mathematicians we don't like
fractions like this because the
denominator is what is it it's
irrational right it's got a sled in
there so what do we do to denominators
like that we rationalize them how do we
rationalize denominators how we're gonna
get rid of this good I'm gonna multiply
by and has a name the thing I'm
multiplying by stop to the saints air
another now conjugate good it's this
right it's the denominator but you
switched the - / + right that would if
you didn't know already is super
important right you should get that down
pledge again now what happens what
happens when you do this okay well all
the on the numerator
nothing much particularly interesting
happens you can just for the sake of it
I'm good but all the denominator that
you use the whole trick by rationalizing
the denominator right on the denominator
something cool happens where we're
taking advantage of a trick namely
difference of squares right you've got a
minus B and a plus B so so that's why
this is ringing bells okay what happens
to the denominator it's just going to be
a squared minus B squared right
five that's a square minus one which we
can work yeah that's four that's four oh
four this is I can cancel stuff here
right if that's 2 / 4 2 over 4 that's
just 1 over 2 right that's I know what
this is that's 5
five what just happened okay what you
did that simple construction with your
compass in your warmup
okay you created two rectangles and the
magic of it is that this similar to each
other just like that in what loop you
created this rectangle is similar to the
bigger one that's kind of cool